we're having one for sure the city of
las vegas will be celebrating juneteenth
this saturday it's at a new location
this year the world expo center and our
own mary jane belliesa is live there now
tell us more about the event what can
people expect this year mary jane
well sherry i mean everyone is invited
to come celebrate juneteenth it's hosted
by the city of las vegas is
actually their second event that they've
hosted so far and they're excited to
invite the public and have it debut here
at the world market center let me tell
you it is absolutely beautiful bigger
venue more people and of course a lot
more shade than last year where it was
outdoors juneteenth became a federal
holiday in the united states last year
and it's recognized every year on june
19th to commemorate the emancipation of
enslaved african americans those in the
community tell us juneteenth is more
than just a fun celebration it's about
recognizing history all while embracing
diversity and inclusion
juneteenth means unity
it means unity and just like you said
everybody's coming together it's not
just one particular group it's for
everybody so many years people talked
about juneteenth but not many people
understood and represented of what it is
and also it was sort of in the
background now it's in the forefront and
i just love it
and of course we were able to get a
sneak peek inside the world expo center
the public is invited to enjoy free
entertainment vendor booths and food
trucks and even drinks for sale again
this is all free the community is
invited to come check it out at the
world market expo center this is the
first time that they're ever having you
know the public come in and enjoy
themselves it's taking place saturday at
5 00 pm until 9 00 pm and there's plenty
of parking here and of course tons of
shade and fun stuff to enjoy reporting
live mary jane valliesa live local now